emil is a non-profit organization
that was founded in late august of this
year
in response to the crisis in afghanistan
that
that started after the u.s withdrawal of
troops
we are currently helping hundreds of
afghan individuals of afghan families
one of our first efforts at the u.s
military bases was a volunteer
engagement day and the intent there was
for us to hold a course on integration
into america
typically the turnout at these sessions
is maybe six to ten individuals
we were welcomed by over 200 individuals
and that was because the team that we
went with a lot of us had touched
the lives of these afghans in different
times of different places
seeing 911 and seeing that such a
horrible thing had happened in our
homeland really hit home for me and i
was in college when it happened i
watched it i still remember on the tv
screen that morning thinking is this is
this a really bad movie like what is
going on right now i started studying
al-qaeda after college and felt like hey
let me go on the ai.gov and see what the
life would look like and really that's
how the journey started i was at the
agency just over 14 years
anywhere i worked it was focused on
counterterrorism and al qaeda
specifically i worked with
americans and also with foreign
government partners i also worked with
afghan allies i was focused on
afghanistan for many many years of my
career i was blessed
to meet some extremely talented
afghans and extremely dedicated afghans
who are true heroes
when everything unfolded in afghanistan
when we saw what was happening there i
decided that this was going to be where
i dedicated my heart and soul they
treated americans like family when we
were in afghanistan they took us in they
protected us and they really signed
their lives over to to us by working
with americans
when this
evacuation
took place and when the crisis kind of
unfolded
with the humanitarian situation in
afghanistan
i felt compelled to
raise my hand and to volunteer
myself and some very close friends of
mine who again had experienced the
resettlement process or had worked on
the ground in afghanistan at different
times we
put our hearts together and decided hey
let's do this let's help
the individuals the brothers and sisters
that helped americans for so long we
know how to work with the afghan
population we know how to deal with the
nuances of the population we know how to
speak in a way that they will listen
when you're shoulder to shoulder with
someone and you're you're standing
together
in a
sometimes extremely dynamic environment
or under very difficult circumstances
you build a bond
and that bond is something that means
the world to them and to us they're
heroes and we are dedicated to helping
set them up for success
one of the things that we're really
focused on is trying to identify
employment opportunities that are
consistent or suitable to the skills and
the talents of afghan allies and their
families we are
having a lot of initial dialogues and
some more advanced dialogues with
corporations that have employment
opportunities across the u.s the
individuals that have moved here have a
variety of skills where it comes to
education but the goal here is to ensure
that every individual
child adult of all ages that they have
full access to
the resources available in their
communities the educational resources
available
so that they can
expand on their education they may be
struggling trying to find food sources
or trying to find shelter in some cases
or trying to find medical care we run
into situations where families call us
and they need help with
pregnant spouses or with sick children
and so the volunteers that are working
on that side of the house they're really
focused on providing moral support and
mentoring and coaching individuals on
how to find those resources
in their communities wherever they are
i think it's going to take years before
we see
families truly self-sufficient
truly integrated into their communities
and that's simply because it's such a
massive volume
we are wholeheartedly dedicated to doing
this work because it's the right thing
to do